You got to start from a place,
put it like this.
I don't know if you heard of this.
Greenville,
where they want to take 70% of
anyone that makes over $10 million,
70% of their income. That's
hilarious. That's hilarious.
It's the dumbest thing ever. AOC, right?
Yeah. It's the dumbest thing ever, right?
I mean, I wasn't calling her a bitch.
No, no, no, no. That, I like her.
Good luck pitch as expression.
Yes. I liked her too. I like her,
but I'll agree with her that,
but I like her,
but what I'm saying is my friend was
like, oh, you know, if the Democrats win,
that's going to get passed because
we hate rich people and I go,
that's the problem.
We're starting at hate.
The reason why you think it's going to
pass because you think people hate rich
people see it and that's, you got to have
a conversation. Here's no, first of all,
you've got incompetent use of funds.
Like where does the money go?
Our techs were psycho
that if you tax the rich,
they're all of a sudden all the problems
will stop existing. That so silly.
You still have incompetent people
that are distributing the money.
They're just create more jobs.
There'll be more red tape and we
get one more in debt. Yeah. Well,
we've got to do is figure out a real
plan for engineering our civilization
better.
That's,
that's what people have to do and they
should be like real discussion from like
real experts, biologists, historians,
people who really understand
how psychologists,
people really understand human beings
really understand what's wrong with our
society today. And we have
an open discussion. But you
know, that never felt that.
But that can never happen. Of
course you can, but no, no, no, no.
Right now because of the government,
because they, here's the thing,
what do you mean that can happen?
It's just we have to look at it in
terms of what a real priority. But no,
it goes by, it goes by the whoever
party's in charge of their priorities.
It's not like my problem is to
make it a priority for the nation.
That's what I'm saying. It's
impossible, but until you have a person,
I believe everything can be fixed.
This is a simple fix.
If you just elect a person that takes
some republican values and some democratic
values, the thing is right now in
politics, you have to be one or the other.
Like if I, if a person came
in and go, you know what?
I liked these republican ideas. I like
these democratic ideas, less role.
I'm a be down the middle and less role
with Polk call being a centrist. Yeah,
that exists. But in these
to win, if that can happen,
it can happen. All of it.
But until that happens,
it doesn't mean though does it every
four years we figured out what happens.
Right? And before Trump won, we
never thought of reality show.
Fucking guy could win, but that
guy won. Yeah, and you go, okay,
well now we know that happens. All this
stuff can happen. This is not like,
we're not asking for alchemy.
We're not trying to turn lead into gold.
We're trying to figure out a way,
but you're going against
the system that then is the,
there's a new system. The new system
is the system of public opinion,
which is readily accessible. Absolutely.
And that's never happened before.
There's never been a time where everyone
had a say in one way, shape or form.
Whether it's through through
Instagram or Twitter or social media.
That's one of the reasons why upholding
the freedom of speech in these things is
so important. Even if people are
saying things you don't agree with,
the only way this all gets sorted out
as we get to figure out a way to express
ourselves and there's going to
be arguments back and forth,
but what you've gotta do is someone's
got to put forth an educated plan,
like a plan that's based on science and
reason and a plan that you can debate
against opposers of that plan.
But when you have people that don't
believe in science, a lot of how do you,
how do you slowly but surely
got to educate people.
It's going to take generations. This
is what I'm saying. It's like the, the,
the momentum of our stubbornness
and our, our, our past and the,
the sort of the systems that
we find ourselves stuck in,
systems of behavior and
thinking and culture.
All that stuff is just
going to take a long time.
We sort the wheat from the chaff.
We've got to figure out what's good
and what's bad and we're doing it,
we're doing it,
but it doing it actively
and it's frustrating because
you're like, God dammit,
this is the worst time.
We still have all these problems.
We still have cops shooting people.
We still have crime,
we still have Wall Street theft.
We still have all this stuff. Yeah.
But you know what? I like him.
But you know what I like is,
we know about it now where it's not
hitting like 20 years ago, like you heard,
let's go 30 years ago you heard Nwa
make that sound f the police and they're
talking about the same things that are
happening today except you would hear the
song and go, oh, that's a great song.
That's not Rodney King. Yeah. Rather kick,
you watched him get the
fuck beat out of him on TV.
And here's the thing about the Rodney
king thing. That guy apparently was, look,
we had done a bunch of crazy shit, right?
He got gotten a car chase with the cops.
Beat the fuck out of somebody before that.
There was a lot going on.
He just got to see the end
of it while this guy is, was
he on? Was He on 10 years?
I don't know if he was he on a
drug and I think he was on PCP.
PCP apparently makes you
look super humans strong.
I had a buddy of mine who got his
finger bitten off while he's on PCP,
so he didn't even know it bitten
off by who? The street fight. Yeah.
It's like he didn't even realize
this fit cause he was, he was on PCP.
He didn't realize how many bit
his finger off then he went to.
Yeah, he had, he had a, his
toe removed and his toe,
uh, put onto his finger. Wears finger.
Used to be, was it a thumb? No,
this is pinky fingers up. Put his
trigger finger, so on one of his,
and he had it curved so he
could always throw ride hooks.
So is when you'd shake his hand.
He's a,
he would give you like this weird
handshake while he would shake your hand,
but there was always one finger that
wouldn't just try to take out the middle.
It didn't move good because they had,
it was really his toe that they
replaced his finger with a toe.
That must have looked weird. It
was weird. It was real weird. Yeah,
but that's PCP son live in that PCP,
like fucking crazy people in
Boston, man. He was a boxing coach.
Oh yeah. I don't know man. It's just
we need to get to a better place. Yeah,
we're getting to a better place, but
I think it's a long, slow process.
I think we are in the, I mean
there's people that say like, Hey,
two to minimize the suffering that
people feel right now is in Justin.
For you to say that is outrageous and
it's just a hallmark of your delusional
perspective. That's not true. This is not
denying the awful things of the world.
The awful things in the world exist,
but if you tried to look
at this as a mathematical
equation, if you looked above,
he would say, well, there's
a lot of problems here.
There's a lot of competing factors.
There's environmental factors like
what are they doing in the world?
What are they doing to the ocean? What
are they doing in the air? Oh Jesus,
everything's warming up and people
are fighting over what's causing it.
Like they not even pay attention.
This is madness,
but look how much knowledge there is.
Look how much discussion there is.
Let's say movements are moving
and growing and people are,
even when they're misinformed,
it's still, there's activity.
There's all this stuff going on.
Even when you know someone says, Hey,
we're going to tax everybody
that makes more than $10 million,
70% like bitch shape, tax and shit,
stop. Just stop, stop, stop, stop,
stop. Just because someone works really
hard, you can't take all of it. Look,
stop people from stealing
money, stop people for, but
if you, if people say, well,
we want equality of outcome. Okay. As
soon as we get a quality of effort,
talk to me as soon as we get,
cause some people don't hustle,
they just don't. And I don't know why.
Maybe it's the way they were raised.
Maybe they have poor nutrition,
maybe they a hookworm.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
But don't say that everybody's supposed
to hit the right spot and everyone's
going to get to this spot and then
after that spot we're going to divvy,
divvy up all the money.
So nobody ever makes more than $100,000
a year in the world's a better place,
bitch. That doesn't make the world better.
Notes that makes the lazy people happy.
That some fucking juggernaut like
Mark Cuban or one of these billionaire
characters is like hustling constantly
and gathering up massive resources. Yeah,
he's playing the game of monopoly
but he's playing at 24 hours a day,
seven days a week. That's
his option. He can do that.
You can't stop people from doing that.
Well you can stop them is from doing in
just things with that money and wait,
maybe you can do is like help someone
like lean towards it like a bill gates
type situation where he does so much good
and so much charitable work and helps
out so many people that you go,
oh well maybe it's not a bad thing for a
guy like that to have all that money he
gives. You don't have to think
of him as just mister money bags.
Like maybe you could think of them as
he does have access to all this money,
but he's also this incredible resource
for hope and change and prosperity for
some folks.
I think like I think people wouldn't
mind giving money to something that they
see being built.
Like if there's work into it,
people hate the idea of just giving
money and that seeing something from it.
Sure.
Guilty.
Giving it to people that don't know what
the fuck to do with it and they just
going to find a use for it because that's
what bureaucracy is. Yeah. I don't know,
man. I don't know. I
don't know. Joe, we just,
I don't know either, but I do know
that it's fashionable to say it.
It's fashionable to say everything
sucks. Well it's, it's easy to say that,
but like you said,
but I really think it starts with if the
government is not on the same page and
they're always fighting, you
can't, you can't move forward.
Then all this great stuff you're saying
can't move forward because it starts
from the top Joe. That's true.
But it starts from the top.
What's interesting is one of the
things that's cool about the government
fighting as you get to see that,
like even the president can't do
the things that he wants. Yes.
He has to consult with people and they
have to agree on something and it has to
be reasonable and they have to
present it to the American people.
And so the people have to
represent their constituents.
And so you're seeing this
really fascinating thing
because you've never had a
guy like Trump in office before.
So you see him say he's going to do
things and then you see the rest of it
doesn't happen on the fuck you
are. Yeah. The fuck you are.
And then you watch this stalemate,
you watch this, this go down,
and you watch these people
being forced to negotiate.
And the way Trump was forced
to talk about Nancy Pelosi,
cause she has so much power, you know, and
you know, he did have to call her a cut.
Oh yeah. He'll will have to call her
at all. Which like the fuck out here.
He has to pay their respect because he
knows now golf claps right in his face.
She's like, man, this
I, it's so fun to watch.
It's so fun to watch right now.